allez allez un dernier effort plus que
de mettre monsieur du snop chère amy je
suis exténué voulez-vous que j'essaie de
le tirer tout seul en aucune façon il ne
sera pas dit qu'un 10 noble enfin il ya
une tâche qu'il s'était donnée pardon
monsieur du snop vous avez failli faire
quoi
veuillez me pardonner amont sur mon cher
et 1000 mhz et champagne et le verbe
faillir dans un sens ce film n'était pas
coutumier qui sont plus prononcées à non
qu'est à ne pas accomplir une tâche que
l'on s'était fixé à mesure je comprends
oui oui oui oui vous avez en quelque
sorte je connais vos qualités pour sûr
je les apprécie vos compliments monsieur
du snow mais il faudrait terminer de
porter votre stand parce que je ma
tournée à finir m'a redonné ma manche et
annoncer attention et un petit peu à
gauche et à droite
la balade en alliant ou voilà à mon cher
à 1000 tels enonces satisfaction que la
vue du rien compris pour sûr là je suis
d'accord avec vous et les boues n'est ce
pas sans vouloir vous offenser monsieur
du snop
vous savez que je vous aime bien mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait le genre de
décoration qui me plaît mais chacun ses
goûts 1
c'est votre stand et l'important c'est
qu'il vous plaît ça c'est que j'aime
chez ruth acteurs cette franchise doublé
d'un authentique bon sens populaire
il est évident que vous ne pouvez pas
apprécié la véritable finesse et de ce
fait de grave
dites moi monsieur du snob
gens comme vous il y en a beaucoup des
gens de ma qualité aux hélas de moins en
moins à quoi bon pourquoi pas ce que je
voudrais bien m'inscrire en jour vous
inscrire oui parce que je trouve votre
système bien pratique oui chaque fois
que vous faites quelque chose qui nous
plaît pas aux autres vous leur expliquez
que malheureusement ils n'ont pas
compris
et bien moi ça me serait bien pratique
pour répondre à mon chef quand je suis
en retard à l'ouverture dont la poste
mais mon cher emile ne devient pas homme
de qualité en s'inscrivant comme dans un
club de sport au nom non mais ne vous
inquiétez pas monsieur du stop là là je
plaisante à bombay fonctionne en a et
parce que j'aime a tourné à continuer
très bien bourré bien fait allez au
revoir monsieur du snarr et dites moi
oui
ne vous inquiétez pas trop hein il est
pas si les que ça votre stordeur allez à
bientôt un je ne sais pas si cela doit
me faire plaisir ou me rendre encore
plus malheureux
enfin google lalalalala que se
passe-t-il monsieur diffa bonjour ma
très chère gelli alors comment le
trouvez-vous mais je le trouve
il est très très original merci ma très
chère me voyez vous ce matin je suis
passé et j'ai vu que casimir avait monté
son stand pour vendre les objets qu'il
fabrique lui même alors je me suis dit
que je pourrais monter aussi un stand et
vendre mais pourquoi oeuvre alors vous
vous lancez dans les amoureux nar pensé
comme dirait notre charte acteurs du
train de plaisanterie je vais exposer
mes oeuvres artistiques haut niveau j'ai
fabriqué un matériau peu usité pour la
peinture ou la sq
mais ni l'un ni l'autre match ira très
chers amis c'est là toute l'audace de
monette et bien écoutez je suis très
impatiente de voir ça mais les objets
que va vendre casimir vont paraître
d'autant plus ridicule que la vente qui
fait est un petit peu particulière en ce
qui le concerne au beau aboyer de quoi
s'agit-il
copé vous savez il fait un peu ça pour
s'amuser il le ramasse par ci par là des
objets qui traînent ils les groupes de
la façon qui lui paraît la plus laide et
puis il vient les vendre on lui achète
quelques centimes et après moi je vais
tout à la poubelle
bon je vois ni un artiste de ma qualité
ne doit pas avoir peur voisiner avec des
pitres bon affaire a mis pour que je
vous quitte car mes objets ont une si
grande valeur qu'il faut que je les
porte doucement vous comprenez alors je
n'ai pas de temps à perdre à tout à leur
marché c'est tout à leur monsieur disney
bien fait un soir je me demandais où tu
étais passé et bien j'étais parti donner
un coup de main casimir parce que avec
son centre il n'arrivait pas porter sa
valise et bien tu as un concurrent
aujourd'hui que monsieur du snob
qu'elles ont honte mais il faut toujours
qu'ils viennent nous dire qu'ils ne
soient pas injuste enfin n'est pas
toujours d'accord avec monsieur 10,9 et
du c'est très bien qu'il t'aime beaucoup
et puis tu sais ça pourra peut-être être
bon pour toi parce que regardons les
grandes villes
les marchands qui vendent la même
catégorie d'objets ce groupe dans le
même quartier
les marchands de timbres de tableaux de
meubles de vêtements et les gens qui
viennent sont sûrs de trouver dans une
boutique ou dans l'autre ceux qui
cherchent à alors tu crois qu grâce à un
monsieur du snob j'aurais vendre mes
objets pourquoi pas les gens qui
viendront regarder les arbres
monsieur 19 s'intéresseront d'être à des
objets c'est parce qu'il n'a pas encore
vu les yeux déjà de casimir cette fois
et sont vraiment très laid casimir je
crois même qu'on peut dire qu'ils
s'entraînent à oui tiens voilà un
exemple
c'est un pot de yaourt à la fraise
accroché après une banale d une dose
était plus affreuse bouteilles en
plastique que j'ai jamais trouvé dans
une autre belle horreur une vieille
boîte de conserve très mouillé ça pour
ça c'est de la vieille paille dans un
pot de fleurs oui on ne peut pas dire
que ce soit très ravissante attention
doucement voilà tout ce monde là où on
est bien mais très chers amis je suis
émue à l'idée de vous présenter pour la
première fois mais petit chesapeake
voici le premier qui s'intitule accident
à 5 heures de l'après midi sur une voie
glissante
voilà
ces bornes spa attend le deuxième set et
une bouteille assassiné par ravaillac ça
alors quelle finesse
quel sens aigü attendu il troisième
s'appelle reste de pique nique de
printemps comme ça mais ses doutes ses
traits et enfin alors là enfin voici ma
fleur des tables qu'en pensez vous bah
écoutez ça alors c'est incroyable
casimir apporte ce qu'il appelait
monsieur du snob ce qu'ils trouvent le
plus joli et ce sont les mêmes objets
qui comprend rien
tu sais julie chacun peut avoir son
opinion
l'important c'est de respecter celles
des zones
[Musique]